hi I'm Sora and I'm Marisa and we're
gonna show you how to make our berry
stuffed french toast the first thing
we're gonna do is get the berries all
set up and funky good yeah we chose this
dish for Pride Month because it reminds
me of when we first started dating we
started long-distance and so I came to
visit me and she told me she was gonna
make me this fancy french toast it was
also the first month of us dating so I
was trying to impress and she did
impress and now we're married so for
this recipe we were using brioche bread
because we both love that but you can
pretty much use any bread you can even
just use a white bread a country bread
whatever you want I always love to put a
lot of berries in mine I think food
definitely plays a role in at least our
community of queer friends and gay
friends in Boston we had this huge house
and all of our friends either gay or gay
queer allies were always coming over to
eat with us and we cook for them and I
think that that was very much us
providing this amazing safe welcomed
space for all of our queer friends to
eat food together share stories and just
have fun so now you have your egg
mixture already take your sandwich and
you dunk it in the egg mixture we're
gonna put this in the frying pan for
about 3 minutes on each side until
golden brown oh my god smells so good
it's the butter the butter definitely
the better in the meantime you have to
make some delicious whipped cream
Marissa is stoic and likes to hand with
all her whipped cream that's a little
love to my farm was very tired alright
we've got our spread ready we have our
champagne with some berries in it and of
course it wouldn't be complete without a
nice dollop of whipped cream a
sprinkling of berries there ready for
this yeah let's do a
we're gonna have a good brunch
that's amazing cheers to us you did it
oh yes
[Music]